newly released data from the u.s shows
inflation rose there at the highest rate
in almost 40 years to 6.8 percent last
month compared to one year ago for
months the federal reserve has been
saying it believes inflationary
pressures in the u.s economy are
temporary but prices for goods gasoline
used cars rent and food have continued
to climb fueling concerns that high
inflation rates are not going away
our financial correspondent jens corte
joins us now of course the reason for
those price rises again shortages in
goods in labor and gasoline as we heard
and it doesn't look like those shortages
are going to be addressed
quickly does that mean prices then will
also rise indefinitely
well i mean nothing lasts forever but
clearly we see those price spikes for
much longer than economists especially
also the federal reserve anticipated a
couple of months ago and what will
happen to prices also depends uh to the
certain categories so if you look at
energy for example who knows maybe the
winter won't be as cold so demand won't
be as high and prices might drop but if
you look at wages for example it seems
that those are rather going up then
down or not moving at all
now i see the christmas tree behind you
christmas shopping probably going to be
very expensive but president biden as we
heard earlier said he thinks inflation
is peaking already do americans believe
in yens
well i mean if you look at the approval
ratings it doesn't look so grand um
there was a recent survey um 37 percent
uh of uh people being asked in that uh
paul agree uh with the economic policy
of
joe biden so an approval rating for his
economic policy of 37 percent that is a
pretty
low
figure but on the other side it's
understandable that the current
administration tries to talk inflation
down because if expectations for
inflation are getting too hot then that
could become
a self-fulfilling
prophecy but then again there's only so
much the administration can do at this
point joe biden already
opened the strategic oil reserve to at
least take some pressure
off the energy and gasoline market i
mean that actually
that trick has only worked so far at
this point
expectation management to manage
inflation thank you very much ian's
quarter there for us thanks for all your
reporting this week
you